hai visto non è successo niente
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi oggi continueremo la nostra
challenge ho messo il vestito che mi è
stato regalato dal rennes
mi piace come vi sta benissimo e ora
dovremo andare nella parte più alta del
castello e vedere se troviamo qualcosa
vi ricordate lo scorso vite una corsa
challenge sbrighiamoci perché sembra che
io per piovere allora secondo me per
raggiungere la parte più alta del
castello dobbiamo salire sopra le torri
pero le topi mi sembrano la parte in
realtà o forse quella porta quale sarà
la torre è giusta il problema è che si
sta anno volando dobbiamo sbrigarci
prima che arrivi il temporale
[Musica]
stiamo salendo sempre di più
lei a ritrovare il mondo più
vi ricordate questo possono il castello
quasi 100 proteste ricerca ma ieri si
lungo mi porto il podio
buonasera devo dire questa è la libreria
del castello per le ricordate
ma questo non è il punto più alto del
castello dobbiamo continuare a salire il
vero troviamo nelle altre strade magari
ci portano ancora più su ci sono delle
scale dietro di te e guarda noi abbiamo
ancora esplorate questa aspetta però mi
è venuto un dubbio e se la prossima
lettera terreni fosse nascosta nella
libreria meglio controllare non si fa
mancare dove potrebbe essere ci sono
talmente tanti libri i libri sono
tantissimi sono anche in lingua estranee
non riesco a capirli
e impossibile cercare tutti questi libri
magari il mistero e il segreto è
racchiuso cuoco ma ci vorrebbero mesi
per controllarli tutti verso proviamo a
salire al piano di sopra
ok siamo attenti a non svegliare il
cavaliere andiamo
vogliamo disturbarlo sarebbe giusto
vedere se era sveglio come stesso
cavaliere risveglio vedi st tormento
storia possiamo farci un sert insieme
forse si entra più forse siamo nel punto
più alto del castello ci sono delle
ragazze qua vediamo
siamo sul tetto del castello loro
bellissimo ora dobbiamo solo cercare la
prossima lettera questa era la parte più
alta
esploriamo tutto assieme e voi lasciate
un mi piace per portarci fortuna feste
guardate qua c'è il chiostro dove
eravamo primi guardate
siamo proprio in alto sarà il punto più
alto del castello forse questa torre qui
ma forse questa donna ne facciamo
ieri è stato un attimo c'è anche una
torre con occhio al tabù possiamo
provare a salire con delle funi è troppo
pericoloso e poi guardate che nuvole sta
per arrivare un temporale dobbiamo
sprecarsi c'è anche tanto vento lo
vendiamo continuiamo ad esplorare il
terrazzo partner fortuna non c'è nessuna
creatura strana finora di buchi magari
mi possa arrampicare da qui da fermo
fermo è troppo pericoloso non puoi
arrampicare salgo quassù non
arrampicarti troppo pericoloso che
guarda c'è un altro passaggio può
passati
la donna di questa parte interna del
castello non l'avevo ancora vista sono
un sacco di parti del castello che non
abbiamo ancora esplorati che questa non
a roma
né potrebbe essere nascosta
sono queste cose
sposata
controlliamo in ogni feritoia del
castello ok non servivano queste
territorio ma che bel paesaggio da fare
sono troppo basso lazio dove dovremmo
andare adesso ma per finito qui c'è
qualche altro passaggio non vieni qua
questo è quanto
[Musica]
è bellissimo vedere il roseto e il parco
del giardino dall'alto dove siamo stati
gli altri giorni vi ricordate guardate
forse c'è qualcosa qua da tutto
[Musica]
tango
ero dimenticata che ho paura delle
altezze che sono simbolo che è questo
che cosa vorrà dire che mi sono potuta
guarda la rilettura tacco dall'alto il
muro e cioè che s'era sulla moto della
colla sito paura che ho paura proprio
che succeda quello che provo a sfilarla
piano stai attenta
vedo che era quella pietra si muove
devono sempre esattamente dove
altrimenti scatterà una trappola
ok non lasciatevi dovere sia una lettera
per reja perché al sigillo con il lupo
non apriamo la quante anche nucleare è
pericoloso potrebbe crollare in
qualunque momento torniamo al piano di
sotto e leggiamo la geniale
ci siamo soprattutto
stanza scheda
mi sono dovuta vedere il quale un
momento per riposarmi perché queste
scarpe fanno male c'è problema è che
siamo di 80 in cui c'è il cavaliere
infatti stava dire facciamo da spicchi
riesce a toccare il cavaliere a scappare
miccia è paura
il difetto beh effettivamente tu con
quelle scarpe però se un po in
svantaggio perché io posso correre
meglio per convincermi di vista quando
tra la sua maschera
hai visto non è successo niente per
fortuna quanti piani ma anche lo siamo
ancora
mancano ancora un paio di piani ma per
fortuna la lettera qui con me
ragazzo abbiamo scoperto una stanza
segreta bellissima sembra la sala comune
di corvonero ora temi bella
[Musica]
e io invece sono riuscito a riparare la
lettera che vuole leggere la lettera nel
parco del castello così forse non
verremo disturbati da nessuno siamo
seduti al parco del castello
ormai lo conoscerete bene e apriamo la
nostra prossima lettera dal re vediamo
cosa si scritto
vi state divertendo nel mio castello
maledetto la vostra nuova prova da
superare sarà trovare tutti i mostri di
pietra ma attenti a non farli arrabbiare
o peggio attenti a non farli tornare in
vita seguito la mappa e buona fortuna
il re seguite la mappa quindi dobbiamo
spostarci da questo castello
dobbiamo andare da un'altra parte è
meglio che controlliamo la mappa e
vediamo dove dobbiamo andare sì andiamo
a prenderla se dobbiamo andare via da
qua mi dispiacerà un sacco perché anche
se un po inquietanti mi ero affezionato
a questo castello di ok ragazzi
eccoci qua in camera questa è la mappa
vediamo subito la nostra prossima tappa
si noi siamo qua dal castello
dobbiamo andare dai mostri di pietra
seguendo questo percorso
dobbiamo arrivare qua quindi questi sono
i mostri di pietra credo dice che
dobbiamo trovarli tutti siete pronti a
finire come in una prossima tappa
lasciato un mi piace qui sotto per
vedere il continuo
[Musica]